there was plenty of temptation on too
hot to handle but there was more drama
behind the scenes that most people
realized we'll take a look at parts of
the show Netflix didn't show us on
screen let's find out which contestants
broke down in tears and who even tried
to leave the show entirely whoa quitting
time going into too hot to handle all
the cast knew that they were going to be
a part of a dating show the no hookup
rule was just as surprising for the cast
as it was for the audience however some
contestants dealt with the news a little
better than others Kel's the accountant
immediately saw dollar signs but some
folks were devastated by the news that
any future hookups would cost them
literally after the big reveal Francesca
and Shirin were upset enough to consider
leaving the show entirely Charan thought
he would have more fun at home and
Francesca didn't think she could handle
it although she's glad she stuck around
the too hot to handle twist was almost
enough to send her packing bad news
Francesca and Shirin weren't the only
people who were overwhelmed at the
prospect of not kissing in front of the
cameras
Harry was so upset about the situation
that he actually cried of course Harry
admits he wasn't quite sober when he had
this intense reaction but still I just
had a whole bunch of wet vomit he claims
he was distraught by the news after
falling in love at first sight with
Francesca Harry felt as though the rest
of the cast was against them and maybe
that was a self-fulfilling prophecy
since their co-stars did get irritated
when Harry's affections started costing
them cash no more cameras the crew
behind too hot to handle took the
premise seriously
which meant monitoring the cast at every
possible moment and we do mean every
moment but when the cameras finally
stopped rolling the cast had an
opportunity to have some fun in the Sun
without anyone watching them after
spending a month together they just
weren't ready to say goodbye quite yet
so the cast stuck around for a while
soaking up the Sun and finally enjoying
an opportunity to relax while in Mexico
shower time at the forefront of reality
TV as we know it today was MTV's of the
real world it promised to show what
happened when strangers stopped being
polite and
getting real everywhere except the
bathroom even on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
Kourtney admits the only time that she
can enjoy some quiet crying time saws
camera is in this room in the world of
reality television this room has always
been a sacred place to score some
coveted alone time but not on too hot to
handle this cast couldn't escape cameras
anywhere including the shower yes Lana
was always watching to make sure people
were actually getting clean in the
shower and not getting dirty to make
this situation even stranger it wasn't
against the rules for cast members to
shower together as long as they didn't
kiss or anything intimate like that
apparently Lana is really concerned
about human hygiene heartbreak Harry
even though Harry let Francesca take all
the blame for their first costly kiss he
did come clean to his cast mates about
an important part of his past it turns
out too hot to handle wasn't his first
foray into the world of dating shows
while fans watching at home were kept in
the dark about this Harry insists he was
honest with the rest of the cast not
only was he contested on New Zealand's
heartbreak island but he and his then
girlfriend Georgia briars won the
$100,000 prize according to Harry they
broke up six months later because
Georgia was upset about another woman
commenting on his Instagram photos at
least she had half of the $100,000 to
keep her comfort during this difficult
breakup Harry claims his past experience
gave him a better idea of what to expect
from too hot to handle and that's saying
a lot considering his extreme reaction
to the rules about affection even though
he and Georgia didn't work out he's
still close with Christian barbarac whom
he also met on heartbreak island he says
the two of them planned to explore
business ventures together in the future
including possibly their own line of
vodka Matthew Smith if you've been
concerned about the career of Matthew
Smith the don't worry because he was
already cast in the role he was born to
play
Matthew was cast as Jesus in the short
film that commissioning because well
just look at him
and this isn't the only surprising entry
on his resume he was also a contestant
on the 21st cycle of America's Next Top
Model although you might not recognize
them without his iconic beer he also
made an unbeaten appearance on new girl
in the season 1 finale but there's one
more seemingly random gig we have to
mention Matthew wrote a children's book
it's called windy which is available in
softcover or as an e-book good listener
let's face it not everyone could cope
with the ever-present cameras on too hot
to handle but while there might have
been less drama behind the scenes being
a part of the crew was definitely a
micro calibre dirty job there were six
different cameras in the main bedroom
alone as well as numerous other units
installed all over the house and in
order to keep everyone honest some
unlucky crew members had to watch all of
the footage and they didn't always enjoy
what they saw or heard producer Louise
Peete said crew members had to
investigate suspicious noises or actions
to make sure nobody had broken any rules
apparently one person became an expert
at deciphering rather unpleasant noises
especially in the bathroom that's a
skill that's hard to work into a resume
talent pool creator Laura Gibson knew
that to make the show work she had to
select the right people to join the cast
this was easier said than done since
over 3,000 people auditioned for the
show dealing with thousands of
applicants wasn't easy but there were a
few things in particular producers were
looking for Laura believed that younger
people would have a more difficult time
staying on track while older folks would
keep their eyes on the cash
the older contestants were Bryce and
Matthew who were 29 during the show
while most others were in their early
20s age aside there were some
contestants who really stood out from
the crowd David felt he was everyone's
last boyfriend before they got married
while here he had a list of hookups on
his phone but couldn't put a face to
most of the names francesca got lucky
she didn't even have to send in an
application she was scouted through the
show through her Instagram account and
before she knew it she was skyping with
a producer moderation usually when it
comes to dating shows drinking and drama
go hand in hand with one another but too
hot to handle is the exception to this
because
Kru was surprisingly stingy when it came
to mixing up cocktails for the cast
according to Rhonda they were only
served in moderation so nobody could get
too crazy maybe because it's hard to
hook up with a hangover but alcohol was
surprisingly limited on this show
sleeping arrangements it's no surprise
that many cast members ended up getting
close to each other while working on the
show after all
they all had to share a bedroom creator
Laura Gibson believes this gave them a
chance to see each other in the raw
after all nothing says romance like
finding out if someone's rules in their
sleep or not contestants not only had to
share the same bedroom but they had to
share the same beds while some of them
were fine doubling up on sleeping space
others protested by choosing the floor
instead david admits that he spent more
than one evening stretched out on the
less than comfortable floor eventually
he switched to sharing a bed with his
friend Chiron at least for most nights
all-you-can-eat there was some definite
downsides to appearing on too hot to
handle but let's talk about a major perk
the cast didn't have to contact door -
if they wanted a great meal everyone had
access to a personal chef who prepared
all of their food to order Harry claims
it was the best food he had in his
entire life and nothing was off-limits
they even had the chance to nosh on
deep-fried Oreos apparently there was no
shortage of temptation drama or food
behind the scenes while some cast
members used this as a chance to indulge
francesca preferred to stay on track
when everyone else ordered beef
wellington she stuck with beet
Wellington she feels better on a vegan
diet and the show chef's had no problem
accommodating her requests at the end of
the day the cast was invited to share a
meal together without having the
conversation recorded the catch they
were not allowed to discuss any show
related drama so the audience would miss
out during meal times
Cassatt ow even though some of us binge
watched this show over the course of a
day filming it took a lot longer to hot
to handle was recorded over the course
of 25 days in April 2019 in beautiful
Punta Mita Mexico the cast moved into
the luxurious kasih tau and maybe if
they were footing the bill they would
have been a little more careful not to
break the rules a single night there can
cost a whopping fifteen thousand six
hundred dollars making their twenty five
night stay
three hundred and ninety thousand
dollars cost calculations putting
together too hot to handle definitely
had some unique challenges compared to
other dating shows according to
executive producers Vicki colar and
Jonah Richards one of the most difficult
parts of production was figuring out
appropriate costs for various
transgressions they wanted to ensure
some contestants would break the rules
to make for entertaining television but
they didn't want everyone ignoring the
pot of gold at the end of the rainbow
it was a delicate balance to keep things
interesting without the jackpot getting
totally depleted by a few straight
kisses this was one part of the show
that wasn't decided on in advance
producers wanted to show how far the
cast would go before assigning a dollar
value to their actions
a simple smooch set contestants back
three grand but they could lose up to
$20,000 on a single date working out one
important aspect of reality shows is
cutting contestants off from the outside
world
this means no phones or Internet so
finding ways to spend downtime can be
difficult but luckily for the fitness
buffs in the group David came prepared
it seems the only gym equipment they had
access to was dumbbells which just
wasn't enough
luckily David packed two resistance
bands a jump rope and other Fitness
accessories he could cope with weeks
away from home but not weeks away from
working out he had to get creative but
says he put together a solid routine for
himself and his friends Kells Matt and
Chiron apparently Kel's got really good
at handstand walking which must have
been quite the site inspiration a dating
show with penalties for physical
affection we sail like a crazy idea but
Laura Gibson got inspiration from a
classic source
she was rewatching episodes of Seinfeld
when she came upon one called the
contest in this episode the cast has a
competition to see who can go the
longest without indulging in certain
activities Laura wondered what would
happen if she put real people in a
similar position and decided a dating
show was the best way to find out Lana
of course we appreciate the human cast
members on too hot to handle but let's
not forget to give credit to the
ever-present Alexa escalada Laura loved
the idea of adding an AI robot to make
the show see more
and youthful and to make sure Lauda had
the right personality for the job
producers decided to make her a cross
between Ellen DeGeneres and Mary Poppins
even though Lauda had a lot to say
producers prefer to keep quiet about her
actual mechanics they want to maintain
some magic and mystery regarding Lauda
but allow us to spoil that for you a
little bit apparently Netflix didn't
have the budget for a super-advanced
voyeuristic AI to keep tabs on the cast
Lana may be more than a glorified air
freshener but according to Capital FM
producers tell her what to say and she
repeats it using a digital voice created
by experts what do you think about the
show too hot to handle who's your
favorite cast member and what do you
think the future holds for Matthews
since he's already landed his perfect
movie role let us know if these
behind-the-scenes secrets changed how
you viewed the show in the comment
section and don't forget to click
subscribe for more videos from the
things thanks for watching and we'll see
you again next time